We are, however, seeing some Republicans very
slowly, clearly for reasons of self-preservation,
starting to jump ship a little bit with the
wild fraud allegations that Donald Trump is
making.
I have two examples for you today.
These are not good people.
These are still people who deserve to never
vote again, but at work again.
No, they can.
I apologize.
They obviously deserve to vote again.
That's not what I meant.
They deserve to never work again.
We're going to start with former New Jersey
Governor Chris Christie backing off of Trump's
voter fraud claims, which are, of course,
bogus.
Christie, a top ally of Donald Trump, helped.
Donald helped was a loose term, but worked
with Trump on debate prep.
And yesterday, Chris Christie said, you know,
you can keep saying voter fraud.
And if there is voter fraud, then we need
to deal with it.
But you've got to produce some evidence here.
And Chris Christie starting to distance Chris
Christie.
It should not have to be said.
Counting absentee ballots is not illegal.
It is not fraud.
It is not corruption.
George, let's say I've been fortunate enough
to be on the ballot a number of times myself.
I've won.
I've lost.
And so as a candidate, you even more invested
in the integrity of the system.
Right.
So if this stuff is going on that the president
is talking about, all of us want to fight
it out because it would undercut everything
that we believe in our system.
But as a prosecutor, that's like asking me
to indict someone without showing me any evidence.
If you're going to say those things from behind
the podium at the White House, it's his right
to do it.
It's his right to pursue legal action.
But show us the evidence.
We heard nothing today about any evidence.
I want to know what backs up what he said
so that I can analyze it.
And let me tell you, if he's right, I'll be
outraged.
And I'm sure you would be, too.
If he's wrong and if he's wrong, then the
American people should be able to make the
judgment about this election that the results
have been fair and this kind of thing.
All it does is inflame without informing.
And we cannot permit information without information.
So Chris Christie was maybe the first prominent
actual Trump adviser to publicly confront
Trump and say what you're saying is not, at
least as of now, backed up by evidence.
It's inflammatory.
He said he already won when he didn't.
He's saying that there's fraud when there
is no evidence of it.
You've got to be careful with that.
We then also heard from former Pennsylvania
Republican Senator Rick Santorum.
Now, he is not a Trump adviser and has even
been a little lukewarm on Trump over the years.
He is a Republican that you could reasonably
describe as pro Trump, although he has had
some hesitations.
He said it was just completely wrong for Trump
to undermine public confidence in the election,
declare victory, all of that stuff.
Rick Santorum, no Republican elected official,
is going to stand behind that statement.
I mean, none of them will.
They will stand behind elements of that statement.
They will stand behind his comment about the
polling and how he can make the argument that
it was suppression and dishonest.
I mean, you can stand behind the lack of transparency
when it came to allowing the votes to be counted.
There's evidence of that.
And he provided some evidence for that.
There are certain things they will stand behind
in that statement because they reflect the
reality.
But much of that statement was was not was
not factual and was at times incendiary and
and not something that the United States should
say or any elected officials.
You said you have evidence to prove it.
And at this point in time, we don't and we
won't until there is an investigation as to
what to happen.
And for I got to tell you, I sat there and
I listened to him talking about the votes
being taken away from him, and then he shifted
to Arizona and said, hey, I can win.
I win this thing if they count the votes.
Well, how can you how can you say we have
to wait and count the votes in Arizona and
I can win this for making it.
But if you count the votes in Philadelphia,
you're stealing them.
The reality is in Pennsylvania, Democrats
voted by mail and Republicans voted by in
person.
And because you asked them to do so shortly
after Trump wrapped up that bizarre press
conference.
Santorum also said that the president's rhetoric
was.
Dangerous and I think what's important to
remember here is that these are not good people
because they're doing this.
Chris Christie supported Trump throughout
the entire campaign and even helped to manufacture
this exact situation.
This is a really important point.
Chris Christie now says, oh, you know, Trump's
got to be careful.
He's got to bring the evidence.
Christie facilitated the current crisis situation,
which Donald Trump has has fomented.
These people are merely trying to self preserve,
but they all need to go.
And at some point we'll put together a full
list of these people.
Chris Christie, Kelly McCann, any of course,
you know, Don Jr., Ivanka Kushner, Steve Bannon,
the whole lot of them deserve to never work
again.
These are facilitators for the most dishonest
and weaponized, least incompetent presidency
that we have had in the modern era.
I could probably say of all time, but let's
just say in the modern era, and I hope everybody
has been taking names, let me put it that
way.
So to take a little bit of a break from the
presidential race, we actually got some very
good news on Tuesday.
The war on drugs was crushed on Election Day,
at least as much as you could crush it in
one day.
In every state where marijuana legalization
or decriminalization or progressive ization
of drug policy was on the ballot, it won in
Arizona, Montana, New Jersey and South Dakota,
voters legalized recreational marijuana.
Incredible in Mississippi and even South Dakota
voters legalized medical marijuana.
South Dakota had both legalized recreational
and legalized medical.
In Oregon, voters decriminalized but not legalized
all drugs, including cocaine and heroin.
Also in Oregon, voters legalized the use of
psilocybin, a psychedelic drug found in so-called
magic mushrooms in specifically supervised
therapeutic uses.
This is huge.
Oregon also is.
So what's going to happen in Oregon is you
will no longer be punished with jail or prison
time for small amounts of possession of any
drug that includes cocaine and heroin.
If you get caught with cocaine and heroin,
you can either pay a hundred dollars fine
or do a completed health assessment, the details
of which I don't yet know.
But we will find out.
In Washington, D.C., voters decriminalized
psychedelic plants also following following
the lead of several other cities.
And again, Oregon, the first state in the
United States in modern times to decriminalize
all drugs.
Marijuana is now legalized in 15 states, plus
Washington, D.C., although Washington, D.C.
still does not allow sales, all measures won
by at least five percentage points in every
state.
This really is not hugely shocking.
Over the last decade, we've seen polls show
marijuana legalization is increasingly popular
in many polls.
Even among Republicans, there is support for
at least marijuana decriminalization.
This is a big rejection of the war on drugs.
It starts to signal a major shift in U.S.
drug policy.
It's going to push for more of the disassembly
of the war on drugs.
But another thing that's important to remember
is we are getting the first steps here, but
we still need to deal with the criminal justice
component.
So, for example, if anybody has a record now
for in Oregon, if you have a record for possession
of small amounts of cocaine, which now are
legal, decriminalized, I should say, not legalize
decriminalized, what happens to your record?
It should probably be expunged.
And that is the next step.
That is the next step here.
That's the next forefront.
Legal cannabis.
You know, nice for people looking to go to
a nice store and get, you know, curated, curated
pot.
But the criminal justice piece is more difficult
and it has to come right after this.
And hopefully we will see that.
Also, I expect to see the tobacco industry
get more and more into cannabis.
And there's also real opportunities in terms
of taking the tax revenue that this will generate
and really doing great things with it.
We're going to be discussing it more.
We're going to be looking to places like Colorado,
even Massachusetts, as potential models of
how this can be managed, how the money can
be used.
But a major win against the war on drugs on
Tuesday.
And we'll keep talking about ballot initiatives
because there's a lot of really interesting
stuff to discuss.